[Music]
what up guys
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about exactly the one topic
that we prepare for you yes because
today we are doing something called
two men and a baby two daddies in the
video daddy and the baby
[Music]
and today's topic is what
is the next jk adventure or your own
personal adventure
man i don't know but i've been thinking
about this
and so hear me out what do you guys
think of this right so
me and darien we got our um we finally
got our like overland vehicles
you got yours right what does he have he
got his like the forerunner right
yeah i bought him a forerunner yeah yeah
that's sick and then so
we have that david has a forerunner and
has a forerunner
oh yeah oh yeah why don't we caravan
somewhere where there's no people
and we have our little adventure as a
going away trip for
or barton jio and taika oh that's pretty
tight too bad you don't have your tundra
man i know i'll buy it
just for that yeah now you have an
excuse yeah that'll be tightly tight
dude
and by that time or hopefully yeah
that's a dope idea
well darren has like three dirt bikes oh
[ __ ] so we can go off-road like we could
park
and create like a little like base with
all of our cars yeah and
we can just go around we can [ __ ] mad
max
you know do some [ __ ] like that that
would be pretty fun let's go to my uncle
spot again oh your uncle spot's perfect
too why do we go more
more nature no i mean i like your uncle
spot you know i um
rented a a jeep patriot or something
that time and then i actually took that
piece of [ __ ] off-roading
it was so bad i gotta do the the dried
riverbed right yeah and i took it to the
uh no that hill yeah i took it to the
very top
and it was [ __ ] scary dude your uncle
spot is the fastest i've ever driven my
truck off road really
cause i was hitting like 70 miles an
hour it was like
and every time it hits a bump like i
could feel my car almost get air yeah
i'm like oh
[ __ ] you should see everyone brings like
the crazy dude buggies or
like crawlers everything especially that
driver riverbed they go
[ __ ] fast that was so fun yeah yeah i
like it because it's private it's our
own spot
i mean that is bathrooms yeah and if you
needed a shower shower
i guess yeah because i've been doing
just
none of that stuff that's cool how many
days do you have in mind or just
specific habitat or like no i guess we
could all
talk about brainstorming yeah because i
don't know
i was just thinking about it i think
yesterday i came up with the idea
i was like oh we should do a caravan
like
somewhere i don't know where though does
do you like that [ __ ] she does she likes
camping okay
it would be tight too if we we could
even do a uh
we could do a small one too as a tester
you know like the
that off-road area next to my house in
azusa
there's no overnight there though oh
yeah that's when people like do like a
one day where we just go there just a
barbecue small barbecue
yeah and then we could do the nah go big
or go home
[ __ ] it i think yeah i think just do it
take three days to drive to vegas
through the back roads oh that's even
crazier oh should we just drop you guys
off
with no bathrooms and there's kids oh
[ __ ] leia freaking
enzo taika what the [ __ ] dude that's
like oregon trail [ __ ]
i've been camping with tyka i think
two or three times and it's it's
i think right now it's gonna be perfect
yeah the first time i went camping i
think he was
eight months and like this is the one
with david right yeah yeah this is the
time where like when you put him down
and if he knocks out you're good but you
know how like when you have a tent it's
paper thin
yeah so like i'd put them down and it
takes like 20 minutes to put them down
and me and you're like oh thank god okay
we can go to the campfire [ __ ] fawn
jumps on some leaves and you hear the
crunch
wakes them up immediately i'm like [ __ ]
so that was really hard
and then we went camping another time
and i think that's when he was
still kind of stupid so he's like trying
to jump into the fire the whole time
like it was kind of hard to watch him
but i think now he finally knows enough
about the world that has the general
common sense i think it'll be probably
way easier he was great on the rv
but excellent at night uh not i felt so
bad for you guys we didn't hear anything
because he would wake up
crying for no reason i just got because
we slept we like the other thing i can't
do an rv
is sleep above the driver's seat you
don't have that little space
yeah okay there's two classical oh my
god i literally felt like i was that's
where you were sleeping
yeah and i never felt like
claustrophobic in my life but i
literally was like
like freaking out that was my favorite
place to sleep on an rv really it's on
top of the driver
area right there well maybe now it's
different but
it was perfect as a kid yeah i don't
know what my next like trip is
i think maybe go to oregon i don't know
what is it to do in like america
just what do you mean people come here
for vacation america has literally has
like more landscapes than any other
country
i don't know variation in landscapes
only it's more like outdoorsy [ __ ]
everything else is like closed so like
anything that we like if we do that
yeah then it's like that gets my fix out
but what else is there like
you could go to alaska if you want to
see some whales and like glaciers
you go to the desert you can go to deep
forests i just want to go to
canada from which part of canada right
now yeah
but my snowboarding right now is really
well i don't know if it's ready right
now i don't know if i could get in
oh that's right because then uh i have
friends who like come we'll get a cabin
and everything and then it's just like
it's kind of hard i want to go to
whistler too for the bike park where's
whistler
uh it's like a massive snowboard park
like it's hella dope yeah
looks like a mountain yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah matt well in canada
yeah yeah and then they have a bike park
there during the summer and then in the
winter it's snowboard
one thing i always wanted to go because
i always hear people say is
aspen colorado it's supposed to be like
it's really good
uh ski and there's another place called
i think you park city utah
supposedly pretty good for snowboarding
too i was pretty close to aspen
when we went to um we were doing our
colorado fan trip
yeah and i i definitely would go back
like colorado is
really [ __ ] beautiful that's where
you guys were like snowboarding i mean
uh skateboarding there's like snow
coming out like yeah
there were no it was so crazy like we
got up at like six and then
um you can literally just park anywhere
and camp
you know and there's just a lot of
places like that and then um
you go like you can go to areas where
there's all these dope downhill windy
roads and there's no cars
so you just take out your skateboard and
you long board and you go
you [ __ ] go fast dude it's scary
because
you don't know how to stop so you just
kind of like [ __ ] it
yeah do you just have to wait until it
levels out yeah you
you wait until it levels out or it goes
uphill uh
and then one but you got to like pick
your roads carefully
because you don't want it to haul ass
too much because it's too damn scary
yeah so you gotta stop before it goes
too steep i don't know but it's it's fun
even for darian because i know he's a
daredevil
he goes the fastest out of all of us he
goes crazy but i realized because
he's he weighs less he doesn't go
fast fast meaning like it's a gradual
speed but he can pick up speed
and i think that was the difference
between us is like when we go downhill
with bikes or
skateboards or anything if we're side by
side because we just weigh more
we immediately pick up speed uh like
even snowboarding right
like we could all pass him up pretty
quick but he does go
fast like and he can jump around and do
all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
yeah yeah and that's what i'm looking
forward to man i got a new board
oh my god i got a yeah i got a powder
board for burton
oh man i just took it out um the day
that we were supposed to go this guy got
sick
he didn't join us yeah good thing too
because uh jio's
responsible i was like i think it's just
a scratchy throw i think it should be
fine
and it's just like [ __ ] no the minute
like during 2020 if you have any weird
feelings
yup you should get tested yeah and i'm
like that's true
but then when i was getting tested i was
like watching your face it's not gonna
be it and it was oh my god [ __ ]
good there to go and then you got more
sick i know yeah
but i wanna i'm glad you didn't go
though because i think it
you know it just kind of made us feel
much more
you know like better but we were
worrying about you though and then we
got the news when we were on top of the
lift
yeah oh [ __ ] i was gonna go too uh
but not to snowboard what are we gonna
do just drink beers at the bottom yeah i
like that because i'm doing snowboarding
i could go one round and i'm dead
because it takes me so long to get down
there is it oh well because you don't
know how to do it yet
like i'm not the best at it if you i'll
probably ski next time honestly i don't
think i'm going to try to learn
something do you know how to ski
i think better than snowboarding what do
you mean you do not obviously i did when
i was a kid
oh but i wasn't any good either i think
it's more intuitive i skied as a kid too
and i remember it just
feels like like roller skates like you
just oh [ __ ] you put it on
and you go forward and if you need to
stop you just go like this
oh maybe i'll try it yeah plus it's like
your feet can move separately
yeah you know how like right now it's
like you have the board and you're
trying to walk straight but the board's
like holding you back
and it's like sliding everywhere and
like i can't even just walk with the
board
oh yeah and then like getting off the
lift it's only stuck to one leg yeah
and then like if you don't ride good
then you crash into someone and dude
like my hands hurt
my leg like remember the first retreat
when i almost broke my ankle oh [ __ ]
that sucks
it's fun though i like snow a lot yeah i
like because i like to be by the
fireplace
you like just so cause it's cold outside
i like the cozy vibes
yeah that's my favorite thing of ski
resorts is that uh
at the bottom you could get you know the
clam chowder and the bread bowls
just for that just because it's like all
cold i wonder if you could get that
delivered
because today's video is spontaneous
because today's video is brought to you
by
postmates baby host mates baby baby
because if you're like me you start
thinking about what to eat for dinner
while you're eating lunch already
i love food but sometimes getting into
my kitchen and cooking something
delicious
just doesn't make it on my to-do list
which is why i've been loving postmates
because with postmates you can get food
delivered without leaving the house
or even opening your front door with the
current state of the world in mind
postmates created no contact deliveries
which i love
so i literally look through my eye hole
i see him drop off the food and get back
in his car and then i open the door
but actually he should be scared of me
because i'm the one with kobe so now
so now when i order from local
restaurants everything gets left on my
doorstep and the app lets me know when
it's been
delivered postmates also offers a pickup
option
which i've been using to order takeout
from my favorite local restaurants and
it's so important that we support and
uplift our communities right now
that's right all the mom and pop shops
need it and what better way
than ordering food pulse meats isn't
just all about burgers and sushi you can
order anything from toilet paper to
phone chargers
from stores like walgreens the 711 i've
gotten freaking ointments for taika i
got
batteries and they'll just drop it off
right outside your front door just
download post mates
on ios or android find your favorites
and get anything you want delivered
within
the hour and for a limited time
postmates is giving our listeners
five dollars off your first five orders
for your first seven days to save five
dollars on your first
five deliveries download the app and use
code
off the record that's off the record for
five dollars off your first five orders
when you download the postmates app or
sign up online anything you need
anytime you need it post made it
postmates it that kind of reminds me of
like the movie phone numbers five five
five
five five five five five dude that's
five five five five
five what that twenty five bucks yeah
twenty five dollars that's good that's a
good amount that's pretty good yeah
man it's crazy because like now
that um so i got into mountain biking
right so
with snowboarding in this in the winter
i got my mountain bikes too
and that saturday i was gonna take it to
aria because you know like when you buy
a brand new one yeah they don't come
with pedals
yeah you got to get those yeah i don't
know why but doesn't come with pedals
because there's different kinds of
pedals so they want you to get the one
that's good for you
yeah i guess so so that day i was gonna
go buy pedals hook it up and i also got
a taika one
three pi taika has one of these yeah i
got a little small one
so i have to put training wheels on it
too but it didn't i was like [ __ ]
all my plans got ruined so how much
money do you have to spend because like
for us like we can buy one like
jumpsuit for like snowboarding right and
that should last us our whole lives
pretty much
but you have to constantly buy them new
stuff every time you want to go on an
adventure right
yeah so uh when we first got into hiking
we didn't know if he was gonna like
hiking right
so we just took him in regular shoes and
then we're like okay this guy actually
likes hiking so we bought him his first
pair of boots and there was 60 bucks
60 bucks for kids hiking boots yeah and
then
but he actually probably put a good
amount of miles on him because every
time we heating out girl
he did now so we have to buy this other
pair which is another 60 bucks so that's
120 bucks
for someone that's only been on this
planet for three years it's so small too
yeah it's like no material on it i know
his feet look like marshmallow
i know so the good thing is he actually
likes hiking
and we go on two three mile hikes no
problem
he could walk two three miles without
being tired yeah
damn like two three miles no problem
so so what does he do on a trail does he
just walk or does he like
stop by and pick a flower and [ __ ] and
do all kinds of random things
uh depends if he's hiking with me he's
doing whatever the [ __ ] he wants
so if he wants to throw pine cones
against the tree all day i let him if he
wants to throw rocks i let him
uh he wants to just like play with the
lizard with the stick
does he pick up those habits and bring
it home or he gets it out there
well for me because i'm like at home he
gets enough trouble because there's so
much order you know
i'm like when i go out there go ahead
and then so when i
when i go and hike with him he usually
comes back with like dirt on his face
like he looks like
he went into like war so you're not
hiking
up a trail you guys are like stopping to
like
throw pine cones yeah and then you go to
another thing
yeah like resting looking at flowers
looking at random things so
like even though it's like two three
miles it might take us like an hour
because we're just like you know
exploring doing whatever
um so yeah but if we really put his
shoes to the test
because the 60 bucks was well spent and
he actually gets good grip so he doesn't
slide all over the place we do you keep
him
we have a mail so in case you have
another kit in case we have another one
but we did we did buy them a second pair
and i'm like [ __ ] do i got to keep
buying these things every year which is
crazy that's why they bought
big things for us yeah and they're like
you'll grow into it
his next pair i bought him uh three
exercises baby
yeah just make him like triple up on the
socks yeah yeah like clowns
yeah cause i think his size his size
he's a size nine in kids
so the next pair of boots i bought them
were i think they're like 12
or something someone just needs to make
a shoe that kind of like expands then
you
unlock it that'll be tight you know yeah
yeah i think that'll make so much money
but isn't he gonna just grow in a week
yeah you know like baby [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] i
don't know if it's like the baby mafia
or some [ __ ]
but like when babies are first born
there's this thing called the bassinet
right
and that's where you keep right next to
your bed because like that's when it's
like the most dangerous the first month
on this planet
there's bassinets that are a thousand
bucks
and after the first three months you
don't use a basset anymore you use a
crib
so that's like to me i'm like through
that's like extortion because you have
to get it
and i think because they know you have
to get it they make it a little
expensive so what do all the people do
without
that they don't i don't know they don't
they probably don't i don't think i had
one
probably not i didn't have one i'm sure
i didn't have any i'm sure they put them
in the middle of the bed
yeah what you're not supposed to do well
yeah but then also like i'm sure they
did right
and then i was born i was conceived
three months after my brother was born
so he was probably still in the bed
oh [ __ ] maybe i don't know if i made you
and her brother
yeah that's what i'm saying like oh they
just kicked him on the floor but doesn't
all afghans just sit on the floor
anyways
like there's communal areas that's like
it's like more comfortable
on the floor and stuff like that i feel
like that makes more sense because the
whole point of the bassinet
or not having a baby in the bed is the
baby can roll off and fall
that's true because most of us spend
life on the floor but maybe it's because
it's dirty on the floor
but asian style i don't know if afghans
do too but you take your shoes off
before you come yeah that's right yeah
so it's like yeah we have tatami floors
really clean no super have to worry
about your baby falling on the floor if
they're already on the floor yeah
that's true where they gonna fall it's
so funny and it's
it's not just like an american thing or
whatever because i see
all types of communities and cultures
doing it
but they people get on the couches and
on the beds
with their shoes that's weird i can't
even go inside the house without taking
off my shoes yeah
it's the weirdest thing to me when i go
to people's houses and they're on the
couch right
and then they have like their work boots
like this yeah it's so weird to me
but people do it though yeah and that's
that's just all culture it's just random
people that just don't give a [ __ ]
i've seen people uh that live their
whole life
in their house with their boots all the
way up until the point they're gonna go
to sleep so they have so then they take
it off when they go to sleep but they
have shoes on like 18 hours a day
dang that's when those stanley
carpet cleaner commercials randomly oh
yeah yeah like they show how much dirt
they take off because like the carpet
looks like brown but it's actually white
i'm like if you take off your shoes
that'd probably last you like you
wouldn't even need to call them ever
when i started wearing high-top like
chucks yoast and stuff that
that's when i was like i don't want to
take off my shoes man
really yeah it's such a [ __ ] to like
take off your shoes so hard
that's what you just wear sandals that's
why i'm always barefoot yeah
you don't have to take off your shoes if
you're if they're already off you don't
even have
yeah you know i already i feel like i
spent most of my day with no shoes on
yeah plus in like muslim families
uh like when you pray you have to like
clean everything like your feet
everything so when you step on the
prayer mat it's all like clean so what
do you do you have like a football
and a in a football it's like uh
well how i was talking we literally had
to lift our leg onto the sink and clean
everything
oh [ __ ] so weird to me the first time i
ever saw it because i was uh
i was doing this like medical internship
in college
so i'm used to like we're live in a
normal dorm right and then there was
this guy that was like
full on like uh i guess like traditional
like muslim
like gear and then he would go into
our bathroom stop muslim gear it's
whatever country they're from but i get
what you're saying oh there's some
people online
yeah i'm a dumbass i don't know but he's
actually from compton but he just
became a muslim yeah yeah um but he
would wash his feet in the sink
and it threw me off the first time i saw
it and he was like explaining to me they
get a bar of soap
and then they wash their foot oh we just
did water and like the way we put it on
like it's a special way and like it
cleans us like
everything so you want to go and like
pray clean you must be super flexible
then to be able to go up
it is good stretches bam like that yeah
and then uh
and like it kind of made me want to be
muslim at that time because every time
the lecture got boring
he just coincidentally had to go outside
and pray and i was like ah this
is tight i was like maybe i should be in
bus go outside and just start praying
too
and then uh yeah but it's multiple times
a day yeah five times a day
five times yeah and then like you can't
like say
it's called uh uh like we call it uzu
when you clean yourself and like when
you have that
and then you have the time to pray you
can't like curse you can't use the
bathroom you can't do anything if it
does it like breaks that so you have to
redo it
we used to go to this mosque in um buena
park where
me and my friend got high and we would
get free munchies there
what we won't get high at the mosque but
like
we would smoke weed at the park and he's
like oh you want to get some food
and then we would go and get like middle
eastern food and then go home
it's because they just had like a
cafeteria open no they just invite
people to come
like worship and eat and they just have
service and then like
we never stayed for the service we're
just high as balls
damn and then so they're very communal
like they'll help out like they'll like
feed everyone
feel homeless do everything so that's so
cool yeah so he's he was indonesian and
then like his
it wasn't his mosque but like someone
invited him
and then he went started going and then
so it was the most weirdest [ __ ] dude
we're like high as balls in this holy
place and we're like oh thank you
and then we're like all right see you
guys later and then we're just eating
the place i went to like they're very
like um
good about like respecting other
religions so they were telling us to
like read the bible read the torah or
read it all like
learn as much as you can and see the
similarities and differences and because
it's all part of like the same
like path you know um and then uh
like one of our like it's called like an
imam like our pastor would have like one
of his friends that was a
um actual pastor come and like check it
out and observe and i was like cool like
this
it was respectful of all different like
cultures and religions do you guys have
the stereotype because like in
christianity
the stereotype is pastor kids are the
[ __ ] craziest
they turn into drug addicts and party
animals is pastor kids
and the muslim are they [ __ ] nuts
dude
i think because the dude's like i don't
have the liberty to say
no no i think it's because if you grew
up in just
a strict muslim household yeah
you kind of some people because then i
have cousins that are just they
just became that way too or they had
other ones where they were like
because they felt so bound like i just
just i feel like psychologically
it's like when you're bound by something
you have for about restricted yeah so
it's like uh
i i feel like that just comes from
having any strict like upbringing oh
yeah yeah that's true
but i think because in say in muslim
cultures
it's you have like say like the pastor
and stuff and theirs
is probably or like our imam like it's
probably um
strict but that goes to
all the households where there's like
it's they're even more strict where it's
like
like your dad or your parents are like
the pastors
when like regular like i don't know how
it is exactly for christianity but from
my friends and stuff
they're religious but then the pastor's
like the most extreme that lives by it
from what we know um and then when they
go home it's like whatever
and those kids of the the pastors are
the ones that are the rebellious you
know i think i grew up muslim
because my mom was more strict than all
the other buddhist people yeah yeah
you